Mr B is literally putting his fans to
labor bro I need your help next time you
see Feast bills in Walmart could you
please clean up the presentation for me
and make it look nice I'm building a
team to do this routinely but I just
need help in the short term dude that's
awesome real what yeah this is a real
treat he he you know there's going to be
hordes of people that are gonna go
they're just gonna be there all day
because there's people so dedicated to
him and want to be noticed by him so bad
because they could win like a million
dollars so weird I swear to God there's
gonna be like one kid in every Walmart
in the whole country it'd be like ask
them to mess up the competitors yeah
that's a good one that'd be like hey
David Dober being like hey next time
you're at dobricks can you all just like
sweep the front of it and while you're
at it if you want to maybe move some
Hershey bars and make sure feasible has
plenty of space that's not even a joke
yeah sabotaging that's a genuine request
I mean yeah
what the [__] I wouldn't complain if you
go uh [__] up the competition a bit you
know